we wish that this had come out a little
more clearly for everyone because we
feel very positive and strongly about
what we're doing and we can see that
it's been widely misunderstood
it's not every day an apple executive
admits to widespread confusion over new
policies related to fighting child
pornography
yet here we are
i grant you in hindsight introducing
these two features at the same time
was a recipe for this kind of confusion
last week apple introduced new child
protection features one related to
spotting and reporting illegal child
sexual abuse material aka csam or child
pornography
and another related to spotting nudes
and text messages sent to and often from
children it's really clear a lot of
messages got jumbled up pretty badly a
lot of people got mad and got mad real
fast not because they don't think child
pornography is horrible but because of
the seemingly controversial way apple
was spotting this content and a feeling
that the company was crossing the line
by scanning the contents of their phones
i do believe the sound bite that got out
early was oh my god apple is scanning my
phone
for images
this is not what is happening
i sat down with apple's software chief
craig federighi to ask some questions
that have been on my mind about these
features good morning good to see you i
broke the interview into two parts
one the features to spot csam two the
messaging feature
it's all confusing but it's important to
understand what's happening and what
control you do and don't have
[Music]
in the simplest terms possible how is
apple looking for child pornography on
iphones so to be clear we're not
actually looking for child pornography
on iphones that's the first route of the
misunderstanding what we're doing is
we're finding
illegal
images of child
pornography stored in icloud if you look
at any other cloud
service they currently are
scanning photos by looking at every
single photo in the cloud and analyzing
it we wanted to be able to spot such
photos in the cloud without looking
at people's photos and came up with an
architecture to do this and it's very
important we felt before we could offer
this kind of capability
to do it in a way much much more private
than anything that's been done in this
area before okay so
let's break this down a little bit more
simply so this is my iphone
i get this update
what is happening to my icloud photo
library so if you are a customer that is
using icloud photo library which you
don't have to but if you're using icloud
photo library to store your photos in
the cloud
then what's happening is
a
a multi-part
algorithm where there's a degree of
analysis done on your device as it
uploads a photo to the cloud
so that the cloud then can do the other
half of the algorithm and if and only if
you meet a threshold of something on the
order of 30 known
child pornographic images matching only
then does apple know anything about
your account
and know anything about those images and
at that point
only knows about those images not about
any of your other images and it should
be clear this isn't doing some analysis
for did you have a picture of
your child in the bathtub or for that
matter did you have a picture of some
pornography of any other sort this is
literally only matching on the exact
fingerprints of specific known
uh child pornographic images
let's pause and talk about what's been
so controversial here the national
center for missing and exploited
children or nikmec has a database of
known csam
sorry for all the acronyms
other big tech companies google facebook
microsoft scan photos you upload to the
cloud to find images that match any in
the repository of nikmic photos instead
apple decided it wanted to do this on
your device for privacy reasons and
that's what a lot of this controversy is
about
on your phone when
images are uploaded to the icloud photo
libraries part of that um upload
pipeline there is a
what's called a neural hash performed on
the image and that neural hash is then
intersected against a
database that's on your device okay
pause again illegal photos have been
converted into cryptographic codes or a
string of numbers that identify the
characteristics of an image what they
call neural hashes
when your own photo is about to be
uploaded to icloud the software
generates a hash of it the device
cross-references your image hash to the
csam hashes
and what comes out of that is basically
some gobbledygook that at that point
your phone can't
doesn't know whether it matched anything
and neither does apple but that thing is
is wrapped up in what we call safety
voucher and when the photo is stored so
is the safety voucher pause again the
system makes a thing called a safety
voucher which holds the match result
that is uploaded with the photo to
icloud then the second half of the
process
occurs in the cloud where these safety
vouchers some math is done on the
collection of all the safety vouchers
and only if a threshold of matches are
achieved after a second pass of math uh
does anything get learned one last pause
in the cloud if an account collects
around 30 vouchers that correspond to
illegal images the account will be
flagged to apple's human moderators who
then review the vouchers and see if they
actually contain illegal images
if they do apple reports the account to
the proper authorities there's a sense
of when i upload something to the cloud
i sort of think okay i've got to trust
this company but on my device i've been
really led to believe in a large part
because of apple's marketing efforts
that this is mine
the info that's on here is mine it is
private i think what's happening here is
there's you're coming onto the device
you're making me feel a little bit like
well we apple can do things on your
device i think that's a
a common but really profound
misunderstanding
this is only being applied as part of
the process of storing something in the
cloud this isn't some processing that's
running over the images you store you
know in your messages or in telegram or
anything else you know what you're
browsing on the web
this literally is part of the pipeline
for storing images in icloud why did you
decide to release this right now was
there pressure to do it
no um
really it came down to
we figured it out we've wanted to do
something but we've been unwilling to
deploy a solution that would involve
scanning all customer data tim cook said
earlier this year we've spoken out time
and again for strong encryption without
backdoors recognizing that security is
the foundation of privacy but isn't this
in a way a back door
i think in no way is this a backdoor i
don't i don't understand
i i really don't understand that
characterization imagine imagine someone
was scanning images in the cloud
well
who knows what's being scanned for in
our case the database is shipped on
device people can see and it's a single
image across all countries we ship the
same software in china with the same
database as we ship in america as we
ship in europe if someone were to come
to apple apple would say no but let's
say you aren't confident you don't wanna
you don't wanna just rely on apple
saying no you wanna be sure that apple
couldn't get away with it if we said yes
well that was the bar we set for
ourselves in releasing this kind of
system there are multiple levels of
auditability and so we're making sure
that you don't have to trust any one
entity or even
country
as far as how
these images are what images are part of
this process
i want to just move on to the imessage
feature which you guys are calling
communication safety and messages
simplest way possible explain it to me
no acronyms
no jargon how does this work
i'll do my best
the capability is you turn this feature
on
for your child and your child received
an image coming in that was
potentially um you know pornographic
content the image would be blurred out
the child would be told this content may
be unsafe and so the child can just
ignore it that detection happened on
device no one was told it's just local
processing um if the child then says oh
i want to look at it
then it warrants the child tells them
about that this could be
unsafe these things can be harmful are
you sure you want to do this child can
say yes now if the parent the child is
12 or under and the parent has turned on
this notification capability the child
will then be told um if you choose to
continue and view this your parent will
be notified that this has happened
because of a fear i think a legitimate
fear of some parents with young children
is
what's happening that my child is being
coached to keep from me
uh while they're being groomed and and
really we think parents more than anyone
are in the best position to
parent okay so i just want to clarify
this technology is different than the
technology you're using with the csam
that's right it is a hundred percent
different okay i lied another pause this
feature is using on-device machine
learning to look for photos that might
contain nudity
how confident are you in this the
algorithms that are looking at these
photos i mean how confident are you guys
going to be that this is a nude image
and not
a rocket ship
right um so this is a machine learned
classifier it's very good it's very
accurate um it will it can make a
mistake right it could it could say a
photo that
it's unlikely to be a rocket ship um but
uh
you know we've had a tough time coming
up with images that we can fool it with
to do to do our testing with because we
wanted to be able to go through flows in
the feature without all looking at
nudity
and it's very hard to fool it but it can
be fooled
privacy experts spoke out about both of
these announcements this week with the
csam feature the electronic frontier
foundation said apple was overreaching
and creating a back door and a
technology that could be abused many
have signed a letter against these
features
who owns this phone there's this famous
apple ad the 1984 ad where apple is
literally bashing big brother
yet with these updates there's this
thought that apple can reach into our
pocket and change our phone in
significant ways i think our customers
own their phones uh for sure i think the
feature we're talking about here one
needs to just continue to be reminded
is about only applying to data customers
choose to store on apple's servers i do
believe the sound bite that got out
early was oh my god apple is scanning my
phone
for images
this is not what is happening this is
about images that are being stored in
the cloud and an architecture
for identifying in the most privacy
protecting way
we can imagine
uh performing that process and in the
most auditable and verifiable way
possible
when this update arrives it could
provide powerful tools for preventing
child endangerment but it's also a
reminder of the control that apple and
executives like mr federicki have over
the products that we own